Today we've chosen a title for our talk
namely, "The Flood Returns."
I wonder what this title brings to your mind?
Perhaps some of you will think back to
a few years ago, when National Geographic
once produced a well-known documentary
in English it was called Before the Flood
and in Chinese it was given the title "Before the Flood Comes."
It, too, was all about paying attention to climate change.
Now, today is not a movie-appreciation session
but you can actually find that documentary on YouTube if you'd like to watch it.
Choosing this title today is really quite fitting.
Why is that? Because, as you know, just two or three weeks ago
there was a climate summit held over in the United Kingdom.
I imagine none of us went there to join the demonstrations outside.
There was also a recent survey
which showed that three-quarters of all young people
are absolutely filled with fear about the future.
And the reason for that is climate change.
So many young people today
feel utterly lost about what lies ahead, because the road before them seems so uncertain.
The flood is coming.
I remember, back in 2009, there was a news story
about the Indian Ocean island nation of the Maldives.
Their cabinet held a meeting, and they deliberately went down to the seabed to do it
that's right, they put on diving gear and held the entire cabinet meeting underwater.
Why would they ever do that?
They wanted to draw the attention of the whole world, the attention of the entire international community.
Their message was: if we ignore climate change and the sea keeps rising like this
then their whole country will one day end up beneath the sea.
And over here, this is the Solomon Islands
the Solomon Islands, located in the Pacific, in the South Pacific.
This clip comes from the current-affairs programme 60 Minutes.
The programme interviewed one of the local residents living there.
In the picture at the very top
what you are looking at
is this man
who, back when he was a child
would
often come here to play.
But now
this island is completely gone.
You can no longer see the island there at all.
The sea keeps rising, and a great deal of land has already been swallowed up.
And by the way, over on your
picture in the bottom-right corner
is also quite interesting.
Because as the sea rises
the plants that once grew there, since seawater is salty
those plants begin to die off.
This is a point
that we'll come back to again a little later.
As the sea slowly rises, more and more land ends up submerged.
And you'll notice it isn't only the island nations affected.
This here is Venice, in Italy.
Because the sea level keeps rising
in recent years it has again and again
suffered from flooding.
I wonder if you've ever heard of the so-called "MOSE Project"?
They planned to build a whole set of floodgates to hold back the seawater.
This was the flooding as it looked back in 2019.
That bridge in the background is really quite famous.
If you've ever been to the Venetian hotel
there's a bridge just like it outside, isn't there?
This spot here was originally a canal.
But the seawater came flooding in, all the way up to
the shops and the pavements, and you can see the boats sitting right here.
And it wasn't only 2019, it flooded all over again in 2020.
In other words, in recent years it floods over and over.
Here in New Zealand, I don't know if you've followed this, but up above you there's a country called Indonesia, and Indonesia's capital is Jakarta, which recently announced it's moving the capital. Why is that?
Because Jakarta sits right by the sea, and as the waters rise it floods constantly; every time it rains, every time a storm blows in, it floods. The reason is that so many people there pump up groundwater, which has caused Jakarta's land to subside and keep sinking; add to that the rising sea, and every year the flooding grows worse, so they've decided to relocate to the island of Kalimantan.
This is actually affecting many countries and a great many people.
For example, over in Bangladesh
many people along the coast have already moved away
to areas further north and further inland.
These people are what we call
climate refugees.
And it's all because the sea keeps on rising.
But it isn't only the rising of the sea.
This scene here, if you follow the news, you'll surely recognise.
This July, in Henan, in China
because of relentless torrential rain
you saw scenes exactly like this: the tunnels flooded, and the casualties were severe.
The picture in the lower left is the subway line that was flooded that very day
and inside the subway carriages, the water rose right up to people's chests.
So why does so much rain fall, and why does it flood this badly?
It's because, as the climate warms and the air heats up
the amount of moisture the air can hold becomes much greater
and so these bouts of torrential rain, these sudden cloudbursts
become extremely severe the moment they hit.
In just a few hours you can get several days' worth of rain
and in just a few days, a whole year's worth of rain.
Do you recognise where this place is?
Probably not, I'd guess.
This, too, was in the month of July
but this one is over in New Zealand.
It rained, and after just a single weekend
this was the scene once the rain had finally stopped.
So it isn't only China
and it isn't only the Northern Hemisphere
the Southern Hemisphere is exactly the same.
Just a few days ago
if you follow the news, you'll know Vancouver was hit by severe rainfall
which cut off all the transport links between Vancouver and the surrounding areas.
Because so many of the highways were flooded
and many of the bridges
were simply washed away.
If you look over to the right
that there is the railway track
the railway line
and it, too, was destroyed.
And you'll find it isn't only cloudbursts that cause this kind of damage.
In recent years, if you pay attention, every time a storm comes you'll hear this term, the "storm surge."
A storm surge means this: at the time when a storm blows in
the eye of the storm is an area of low pressure
which pulls the seawater upward.
So every time a storm hits, the tide rises higher and higher.
And that is what we call a storm surge.
This was back in 2005, over in the United States
the scene after the rising sea came and struck New Orleans.
So it really doesn't matter what your
particular city happens to be like
even a country like the United States
you'll find it floods just the same.
As I mentioned just a moment ago
rising seawater causes the plants along the coast to die.
In fact, people later studied why Katrina caused such catastrophic flooding in New Orleans.
On the one hand, of course, it was Katrina itself
the winds were especially strong
and on top of that, some of the levees broke.
But there was also one very important reason, and it is this:
as the sea kept on rising
it killed off the plants in many of the coastal marshlands
so that along the coastline
there was no longer any buffer zone left to protect it.
So when the storm finally came
the winds, and the great sea waves
struck the city directly.
This here was
the situation with Katrina back in 2005.
And this is Hurricane Sandy, in 2012.
I don't know if you recognise where this is, but this is New York.
right on the east coast of the United States.
And it's worth pointing out that New York actually lies at over 40 degrees north latitude.
The word "hurricane" simply means a great wind.
If it were in Hong Kong, we would call it a "typhoon."
Its proper scientific name is actually the "tropical cyclone."
that is to say, a cyclone of the tropics.
As the name itself suggests, these storms all form in the tropical regions.
Yet New York sits at over forty degrees north.
So you can see how global warming is now driving many tropical disasters
such as storms striking far to the north, and it seems to be becoming a new normal.
Likewise, if you've ever been to New York, you'll know the lay of the land there.
The rising sea, together with the storm surge
flooded Manhattan, specifically Lower Manhattan.
You know, New York actually has a nickname
the "City that Never Sleeps."
Lower Manhattan is basically a financial centre
lit up around the clock, twenty-four hours a day
because of all of the
financial trading.
As it turns out, many financial institutions keep their computers down underground.
And that particular flood
caused very serious damage.
In fact, it took several years afterward to slowly recover from it.
The subways were flooded in exactly the same way
and swarms of rats came scurrying out
as if giving the whole city a thorough washing.
In this picture on your right
it's hard to imagine a subway station, usually so busy with people, completely underwater.
You can see the divers there carrying out the search and rescue.
This is Macau, back in 2017, struck by the typhoon Hato.
Because of this storm surge, the seawater came pouring back inland
leaving the whole city in this state.
And here, too, the casualties were severe.
I didn't actually put up any of the photos from Hong Kong
but you'll notice that every single year
whenever a storm comes
in recent years, Hato in 2017, and Mangkhut in 2018
you'll find the coastal areas, whether it's Tseung Kwan O
or Heng Fa Chuen and other low-lying spots
the coastline gets battered by the waves again and again.
And speaking of all this
I'm reminded of a verse in the Bible, in Luke chapter 21.
The Bible describes the state of the world before the Lord returns
and among those words is this one line:
on the earth distress of nations
in perplexity because of the roaring of the sea and the waves.
The Bible also speaks about our last days
and one of the disasters it names seems to be the very waves of the sea.
We've just been looking at this rising of the sea, at storm surges; and in fact, I first noticed this verse back in 2004
and that was because of the great South Asian tsunami.
And of course there was also the tsunami triggered by the great East Japan earthquake in 2011.
These events all seem to be telling us something
this very situation, that because of the waves of the sea
people are gripped with fear and confusion.
And this reminds me of something the Bible records in particular.
When the Lord Jesus was on earth, He once helped His disciples out on the Sea of Galilee.
They suddenly ran into a fierce storm; now, some of the disciples were fishermen and had seen storms before
but the storm was so violent that they even thought they were about to die.
Yet the Lord was there asleep in the stern; they woke Him, crying out, "Lord, we're perishing!"
The Lord got up, rebuked the wind and the waves, and made the whole storm completely calm.
I find this account recorded in the Bible deeply meaningful.
On the one hand, you see the Lord Jesus
He truly is able to rescue us out of every danger.
And on the other, it shows that the Lord can calm any storm.
No matter what it is, in your own life
whatever hardship you happen to meet
whatever blows come, whatever storms arise
the Lord is able to calm every single storm.
If a Christian friend has invited you here today
the truth is, your Christian friends would be very glad to share with you how the Lord has helped them calm the storms in their own lives.
Alright, let me pose a question to everyone.
In this glass here, it's filled up with ice, and filled with water too, right up to the very brim.
After a while, once the ice has melted, here is my question for you all: will the water overflow the glass, or will it not?
It won't.
It won't, will it? Very impressive indeed.
So what am I really getting at? Water is a very special thing, and not just in its structure, because it is H₂O; the H is hydrogen, which, as you know, is itself flammable, and the O is oxygen, which itself supports combustion.
And yet, remarkably
hydrogen combined together with oxygen becomes water, and water is able to put out fire.
There's another special thing too: everything expands with heat and contracts with cold.
The lower the temperature falls, the more the volume of water shrinks down.
But here is the strange part.
When it reaches 4 degrees Celsius
its volume
shrinks right down to its smallest point
and then it shrinks no further at all.
At 3 degrees, then 2, then 1, and at 0 degrees when it freezes, the volume actually starts to expand.
And so its density, instead of rising, decreases.
And because the density is now lower, you'll notice the ice floats on top of the water.
So you see, ice really is quite a special thing.
And why is that? I believe it is the mercy of God.
Just think about it, if water became denser as it froze and sank down to the bottom
then every single living creature in the sea would die.
Just imagine it, it would be like a person walking to the edge of a cliff, and the moment they fall off, they're dead.
But you'll find it's a wonderful thing: when water freezes, its volume actually expands instead, its density drops, and so it floats on the water.
There's one more special thing too. What is it? You can see the ice looks quite large, can't you?
But when the ice turns back into water, its volume actually shrinks; because, as I said, freezing makes it bigger, and turning back to water makes it smaller again.
And the volume it loses is precisely the part that had been sticking out above the water.
So some people say, when you see an iceberg, you'd better get well away from it.
In fact, the part of an iceberg sticking out above the surface is only about 11 percent.
The other 89 percent lies below the water.
So a full ninety percent of any iceberg lies down beneath the surface.
So when you spot an iceberg from far away
the ice beneath the water may already be very close to you, without your ever knowing it.
Now, ice that floats on the ocean, up on the surface of the water, doesn't actually cause the sea to rise; it only leaves the polar bears with nowhere to stand, because as the ice melts they may have to travel very far to find a foothold.
In other words, what really causes the sea to rise
is mainly the ice sitting on the land.
And what do people usually mean by that?
They mean Greenland, and Antarctica.
Here's a news story for you.
Just this past August
you'd find it quite remarkable
it rained in Greenland for the very first time.
At first I really didn't think much of it.
My immediate reaction was something like this:
surely it must have rained in Greenland before?
Why do you think this made it into the headlines?
Well, just think about it: Greenland is to the east of Canada, very far to the north.
It really shouldn't be raining there at all, it should be snowing, do you see?
So the first recorded rainfall in Greenland shows that the temperature has genuinely risen.
And on your right, you can see those dogs pulling along a sled
they're not walking on water; it's that the surface layer of the ice
is melting very, very badly.
So when you photograph it from this angle
it looks as though the dogs
are walking right across the surface of the water.
This is actually in Greenland
that is to say, Greenland
the melting of the surface ice there.
Someone has calculated that if all of Greenland's ice were to melt
the sea would rise by around twenty-odd feet, roughly two storeys high.
Two storeys
twenty-odd feet is really very high; I wonder how close to the sea your homes happen to be.
I wonder for all of you
which floor you live on.
But what if the water, the ice of Antarctica, were to melt, what then?
Antarctica holds nine times as much ice as Greenland does.
That means if the ice of Antarctica and the ice of Greenland were to melt together
the world's sea level would rise up by around 21 or 22 storeys.
Would you like to picture that scene for a moment?
And this is only the rise caused by the land ice melting.
In fact, when the temperature rises, there is another factor, another influence, that is very significant.
It's that, as the temperature climbs, the seawater itself expands.
And this expansion of the sea, which raises the sea level, is actually a very serious matter.
This February there was a news story.
For the very first time, a Russian icebreaker was able to cross
a passage in the Arctic Ocean that had never once been navigable before.
So what does this actually tell us?
It tells us that in the Arctic Ocean, at the North Pole
the ice has grown very much thinner.
Now you might well say
hold on a moment, you've only just finished telling us
you said that at the North Pole
ice melting on the sea won't affect the height of the water.
But here's the thing
there are still other effects.
In recent years, haven't you often been hearing about heatwaves?
We went through one this June.
This June a heatwave struck Canada, and Canada is very far to the north.
Vancouver sits at 50 degrees north latitude.
But just think of Vancouver's
neighbour, the city of Calgary.
In Calgary
it reached over 40 degrees Celsius.
You might well find that very strange.
Why would there be a heatwave so far north? If you look at the heatwaves of recent years
they're often caused by one thing, what's called a "heat dome."
In Chinese it's popularly known as a "heat lid."
a lid, as in a covering lid.
Just imagine you're cooking something, boiling some water.
With a lid on, or without a lid
isn't it different?
With the lid on, doesn't it come to a boil much faster?
Because all of that steam simply can't escape.
The steam can't get out
so it boils very quickly.
It's exactly the same principle at work.
Because in this picture, you can see
can you see, there's a jet stream right here
that is, a high-speed air current, way up high in the atmosphere.
It forms an area of high pressure
so that all the air trapped down beneath it
even though it isn't hot in itself
simply cannot disperse.
It has no way at all to escape.
It's just like putting a lid on the pot.
So that within a very short span of time
all of that trapped air
heats up extremely fast.
So just think about it, at over 50 degrees north
you can still record over 40 degrees Celsius.
That really is quite staggering.
Alright.
But there's something I want you to notice.
I'm not really here just to introduce the heat dome.
Let me add one more term while we're at it.
This kind of air-current phenomenon
is actually called an "Omega Block."
because its shape closely resembles the Greek letter Omega.
What I really want you to notice is the influence of the high-altitude jet stream.
You'll find that because of the way it wanders
hot air gets trapped, and so you get heat domes, and heatwaves.
And likewise, because of this very same wandering
you'll see it drives the cold air out of the Arctic
sending those polar vortexes down toward the south
reaching much further south into some regions.
So in recent years you constantly hear news of
many places suffering from heatwaves
while at the very same time
many other places
are hitting record-breaking cold.
There was even a time
on one occasion
when Toronto
recorded a ground temperature colder than the Arctic itself.
And why is that?
It's because of this very phenomenon.
You might want to ask a question here.
Why does this jet stream wander about like this?
Well, the reason the jet stream wanders
is that it has grown weaker.
Because it has weakened, because it has slowed right down.
Just imagine it, it's like a river.
when it reaches its lower course, when it reaches the flat plains
doesn't it slow right down? Because the slope is no longer as steep.
And in order to keep moving forward, doesn't it begin to wind about?
That river starts to meander, doesn't it?
Well, it's exactly the same situation here.
Because the jet stream
has weakened and slowed down
it begins to wander; and because of this wandering
the heatwaves I spoke of earlier, and those invasions of Arctic cold, are becoming more and more frequent.
Alright, so now you'll ask a question: why has it grown weaker?
Well, this actually proves one thing: that the Arctic has warmed a great deal.
Because the difference between the Arctic's temperature and that of the surrounding regions
the greater that difference is, the faster the surrounding air rushes in toward the Arctic, and the stronger the jet stream becomes.
But once the Arctic warms up, that temperature gap shrinks, and so this jet stream grows weaker.
In fact, research shows that global temperature change isn't uniform at all, and in the Arctic the temperature is rising four times faster than in the surrounding regions.
In other words, the Arctic region is warming up far more quickly.
You might want to ask a question, namely: why is it warming so very fast?
One of the main reasons is the great Siberian wildfires.
This fire has actually been burning for several years now; and in fact, the largest fire of the entire 21st century
is the great blaze burning this year in Siberia, in Russia.
The area of this one fire, compared with North America's
the wildfires of California and Canada put together
add to that the fires of Europe, and of Turkey, and this one is still larger in area.
This was captured from high up above
the situation of the Siberian fires; and you'll notice, aren't there many spots where there's no smoke at all?
Why is it so strange? Why can I see only smoke, and no actual flames?
It turns out the fires in Siberia, within the Arctic Circle, are very peculiar indeed.
This kind of fire has a name: it's called a "zombie fire." And as the name suggests, do you know what it means?
You can't smother it, and you can't put it out.
Why is that? Because inside the Arctic Circle it's so cold
that after many of the plants die
they don't decompose.
So beneath the soil there's a great deal of organic matter.
And when a fire breaks out, sometimes these flames
will burn their way down underground.
And once they've burned down underground
you'll find that
you simply cannot put them out.
But given the chance, they'll burn their way back up again
to the surface.
So this fire has, in fact, been burning for several years now.
Does it have any consequences?
This here is the ground, captured in satellite imagery.
You can see all those points of fire, can't you?
Underground, it's still burning away.
But the moment it gets a chance, it breaks right out to the surface.
The whole landscape smoking over, that's exactly what's happening here.
You might ask, the great Siberian fires
these Arctic Circle fires, what impact do they really have?
Last year there was a news story just like this.
You see the picture at the top, that river, has it not turned completely red?
And it's not because of any blood.
It's rather because of
an oil spill.
You see, the ground in the Arctic Circle
is called permafrost, ground that has built up a great deal of ice and frozen solid.
And on top of it sit many oil refineries, and many storage tanks.
But as the Arctic Circle warms and this ice melts away
many of these facilities, the storage tanks for instance, subside, and start leaking oil.
This was the spill back in May of last year, and it was a genuine ecological disaster.
If you go to Siberia these days, you'll often see craters just like these.
Looking at the people standing beside them, you can grasp just how huge these craters are.
So why are there such enormous craters?
Who would have the time to dig such holes? In fact, they weren't dug out at all.
It's because the permafrost has warmed up and the ice has melted
releasing the methane that had been trapped down in the ground.
And this methane
here you can see
it's rather like a bubble.
That is, down beneath the soil
beneath all that vegetation
there's a pocket of methane gas.
And sometimes it simply explodes
which created those very craters you saw a moment ago.
And those bubbles down beneath the water's surface
are all of them methane.
If you go and find some of the photos online
there are people playing around with it
right there on the ice
they bore a hole into it, and then set it alight.
Now this methane
as a greenhouse gas
methane's effect is actually 20 times greater than that of carbon dioxide.
In other words, take a given volume of carbon dioxide and its effect on temperature
swap it out for methane, and its effect is a full twenty times as strong.
So someone has actually studied this
and what did he say?
He said that once Siberia's methane is released
the impact would equal that of all the world's carbon dioxide emissions combined.
That is an enormous crisis indeed.
This also brings to my mind, in the Bible
another verse.
In the Book of Revelation, speaking of the days of disaster still to come
an angel pours out his bowl upon the sun
and the sun is given power to scorch people with fire.
Already, some places are hitting over 40 degrees; I mentioned Vancouver just now
and Calgary.
And some places have even reached over 50 degrees.
As I was saying, if this methane were to be released in that way
then for the temperature of the whole planet
the effect could come on very quickly
very abruptly indeed.
So if you were to ask me
this idea of the sun scorching people
I don't think it is
some far-fetched fairy tale at all.
In fact, there are already signs now showing us
that this global warming
can indeed
turn very fast
and grow very severe.
In this picture here, it lets us see
the situation of the great forest fires.
We've already talked about the Siberian blaze.
You can see it right here.
And here you can also see several more fires.
This one here is the Amazon rainforest.
This one is the Congo Basin, in Africa.
And this one is Borneo, in Indonesia.
All of them are tropical regions
all of them are tropical rainforests
rainforest zones
and all of them are burning very severely.
We've already spoken about the Siberian fire.
But what about the Amazon rainforest?
In fact, many of the Amazon fires are deliberately set by people.
Some of them are for felling the trees, to take the timber.
But more often, they burn down the forest afterward in order to raise cattle.
And why is that?
Because the market price of cattle, the value of the cattle, is high.
They can be sold off for a good deal more money.
So you'll notice that one of the themes at the climate summit
was to offer subsidies to certain countries
countries such as Brazil, for example
so that it would ban people from clearing the Amazon rainforest.
But the truth is
I'm not sure whether by now it might already be a little too late.
And why is that?
In recent years many studies
have shown the Amazon to be the world's very largest
tropical rainforest zone
you could even call it the earth's first lung.
But here's the thing
some studies show
that the Amazon's carbon emissions
have now surpassed its carbon absorption.
Generally speaking
a rainforest, when there's sunlight and photosynthesis, draws in the carbon dioxide from the atmosphere and turns it into the carbon of its trees; and that is what we call carbon absorption.
But why are the emissions now greater? Well, for one thing, when it catches fire, doesn't it release enormous amounts of carbon dioxide? And it also emits a great many carbon particulates.
The trend over these last few years is that the Amazon's carbon emissions have already exceeded its carbon absorption.
And it makes me think, these days, isn't there always this coronavirus around? And the problem it causes is pneumonia.
Pneumonia means you can't breathe; it's as if the earth itself has come down with pneumonia.
Then there's also the Congo Basin in Africa that I mentioned earlier.
This one you could call the world's second lung
and it, too, is a tropical rainforest zone.
In the two photos over on your right
you can see that the firefighting equipment there is really quite primitive.
How do you even fight a great fire like this?
Just with those things, spraying a little here, a little there.
Like a water pistol, how could that ever put it out?
But how did these fires actually start?
In fact, they were set deliberately by people.
Because over in Africa
in order to get food, you have to farm
and how do they go about farming?
They use a method that's called "slash-and-burn."
That is to say, they burn down a patch of forest
and that gives them a clearing to work with.
The dead leaves even act like a fertiliser to help the crops along.
And then they plant their crops right there.
And after they've farmed it for a few years
that ground becomes overrun with a great many weeds
so the people move off elsewhere, and burn down yet another patch.
And the plot they'd farmed first
is simply left
to slowly recover, and grow all its plants back again.
This is actually how it has always worked, all along.
This slash-and-burn method of working
is called "slash-and-burn cultivation."
So why has it now spiralled so completely out of control?
This actually leads us on to another problem.
Because there are more people now.
Because the population has grown so much
those abandoned plots have no time
not enough time left to recover.
Because there are so many more mouths to feed
they have no choice but to keep on burning
and so the forests are given no time at all to recover.
And so the world's second lung has come down with pneumonia as well.
And this brings us on to the second problem.
And it's that over these last hundred years or so
the world's population has grown at a breakneck speed.
As you can see here from this chart
in 1930 the whole world had 2 billion people.
But by this year, and it's already late November now
the global population has reached 7.9 billion.
According to the projections, in spite of the pandemic
by the end of next year, perhaps
the world's population will break right past 8 billion.
That is to say, going from 2 billion
all the way to 8 billion
in less than a hundred years, all told.
This is a very serious problem indeed.
Because when the population grows so large
the earth's resources are limited.
And which regions are seeing the population grow most explosively?
It's in Africa.
So some people have even estimated
that within a few years
the world's largest city will not be New York, nor will it be Tokyo, but a place in Nigeria called Lagos.
Africa is where the population is growing the fastest, and then there's the Middle East region too.
And there's India as well, of course; and China's 1.3 billion are actually ageing very rapidly indeed.
That's why in recent years they've relaxed the one-child policy, encouraging, even urging people to have two or three children.
When there are so very many people, some things simply can't be helped.
So you'll notice that the climate summit didn't even touch upon this issue.
Instead, it leaned entirely on the carbon-emitting nations; the biggest emitter of all is China, and the second is India
both of them countries with well over a billion people.
But you know full well that these promises are only words on paper.
Why is that? Because just last month, for instance
you saw China facing a power shortage up in the northeast, didn't you?
Winter comes around once again, and once again there's no electricity.
And no one even knows where that heating is supposed to come from, or how.
And in China, the power is very often generated by burning coal.
The population is enormous, and there's a power crunch on top of it.
Not to mention that all of that manufacturing needs electricity too.
And the power comes mainly from the burning of coal.
So how can it possibly promise to cut its emissions?
So really
this is a very big problem indeed; and in the picture on the right
many people are now concerned with what's called the earth's carrying capacity.
That is to say, just how many people can the earth
with its land area, and its resources, actually manage to support?
Over these past few decades many people have studied this
and most scientists share one consensus, which is this: that the world's
resources can supply around 8 billion people.
But don't forget, with all of these natural disasters and this shifting climate
and I haven't even mentioned drought today
you can imagine that the earth is really a kind of balance.
When some places are being drenched with such heavy rain
then you can well imagine that other places are suffering the most extreme drought.
California is one such example.
And these disasters, at the very same time, lower the earth's carrying capacity.
So really, this is a problem that no one even knows how to solve.
And so, speaking of all this, I'm reminded of a certain ship, the Titanic; the Titanic sank because it struck an iceberg. The story goes that at the moment it hit the iceberg, the captain immediately called a meeting, and because the ship's designer happened to be aboard, and the owner too, they all gathered together
and after inspecting it, they discovered that at the bow, the first, the second, the third, the fourth, and the fifth compartment, that is, the ship's holds, were all taking on water.
And that designer grew very anxious indeed
because he was the one who had designed the ship.
So the captain asked
this water coming in, can it be pumped back out with the pumps?
Everyone looked at one another, and they already knew exactly what was about to happen.
Pumping out the water could only buy them time
just a few minutes, that's all.
And why was that?
Because this ship
with three compartments, or four, flooded, could still stay afloat
but with five compartments gone, there was no way it could stay up.
So the ship's owner asked
the owner said, how can this possibly be?
This is her maiden voyage, her very first one.
And that designer answered him
this ship is made of steel
and she will sink.
It's just a mathematical certainty
that is to say, it is a mathematical inevitability.
And when you look at everything we've just seen
it really is a very hard thing to face.
It reminds me of a few years back, when Al Gore, after he'd left office as the US Vice President, turned his attention to global climate change
and made a film, called An Inconvenient Truth.
What was the Hong Kong Chinese title again? "The Truth of Despair."
And I feel that, up to this point, there really is no hope at all.
Perhaps you'll say, the whole world can join hands and cut its carbon emissions.
But as I mentioned earlier, at the very least it overlooks one enormous problem
and that is the problem of population.
And getting the nations to take turns cutting emissions together is itself another problem.
So this is exactly why seventy percent of young people
have so little hope for what lies ahead
and are utterly filled with fear.
And thinking it all over, I feel
that if there really were no hope at all
I honestly wouldn't know what on earth to share with you.
But here is something precious.
At its very end, the Bible leaves us with this one saying
and it's spoken by the Lord Jesus Himself.
The Lord Jesus, He sent His angel
to testify these things to the churches, and what did He say?
There's a line that follows; what is it that He says?
He says: I am the bright morning star.
You see, the deeper the night grows, the darker and the colder it becomes.
And at the coldest hour of all, just before the dawn
the morning star appears.
And when people see the morning star, they know the dawn is very near.
So what does the Lord mean by this?
He means to give people hope.
That when you see Him
the dawn is close at hand.
And why is that?
Because the Lord Jesus has already promised to prepare a place for us.
And once He has prepared that place, He will come again to receive all who believe unto Himself.
So the state of this whole world
is really meant to prepare people's hearts
to let people know
that in the world there is no hope.
But how precious it is
that those who have the Lord Jesus
they have a living hope, which is that the Lord Jesus is coming back
to receive us unto Himself.
And now, I'd like to share a hymn with you all.
This hymn is called "The Lord, Like the Bright Morning Star."
It brings to us hope, it brings to us light
so that even in our despair we can still see the way out, far in the distance.